lữ kết thàn điện đường ở vinh, kết trên cải hiết tích. Mất nhân viên phải quyết sĩ lợi chức nhiều người.
Vụ việc tại nhà hàng gờ gờ đá tủ sử chủ ý của zưa loạn khi một thích hàng có hay nông gây trên cải với nhân viên phục vụ sau một sự cố nhỏ,
theo một kết thàn của mặt tại nhà hàng gờ thành phục vinh khi ra định việc khác đang ăn tối tại nhà hàng trong quá trình phục vụ.
Một nhân viên chè tôi đã sơ sất khi rất cốn và nồi lâu khiến lửa từ cốn, phô tình bản vào máy của cho nhỏ còn cụp vi khách,
sẫn để một vết mọng nhẹ ở ngon tay út của mẽ ngày sau khi phát hiện tàn sĩ cố, nhân viên đã nghiên trong tập lửa trên này đẹp vào cùng với các li nhà hàng để đi sình lỗi phát trình ăn ra định.
Lắm đầu, việc kích ngày yêu cầu kìm chá khá mê ra, đi sách mình về nhân dự cố, sẵn đau yêu cầu nhân viên phục vụ phục ra sử lượng con mình.
Tuy nhiên, kinh nhân viên vừa sất hiện, việc khác mục lời la vào phục vụ chiến mắng nhân viên trong tình hôm nay,
cả nhân viên lẫn của li nhà hàng liếu vất lửa không kịp că ngăn, một nhân viên khách đánh những trong khan tịp,
và điều nhân viên phục vụ vào trong, sự việc chiến dân lại ở đó, việc kích này tiếp tục yêu cầu nhân viên phục vải sát mọi sinh lỗi lần nữa,
và yêu cầu mình lại quyết xuống trong tình trạng hôm nay, nhân viên đã thực hiện yêu cầu này.
Hình ạng nhân viên quyết sinh lỗi đánh được một khách khẳng khách chup lại với chết sẻ, kể sôn sau xíu luôn.